public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
françois bayrou le président du modem et
le maire de pau est l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir monsieur
baroin
et merci d'être avec nous donc présents
à ce rendez vous que vous a proposé
public sénat avec la fp avec les échos
et radio classique
et nous sommes à 26 jours maintenant du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle vous répondrai à trois
grandes questions entre affaires et
défiant cette campagne qui exacerbe le
ras-le-bol des français est elle un
danger ou est elle définitivement pourri
vous demandera jean-francis pécresse
deuxième question emmanuel macron avec
qui vous avez dans que conclut une
alliance et il le dauphin de françois
hollande
selon le mot de françois fillon hier
soir questions que vous posera des bras
claude enfin quelle majorité législative
pour emmanuel macron ans qu'elle serait
donc cette majorité centrale que vous
vous appelez de vos voeux depuis si
longtemps vous répondrez à mickaël
szames s mais d'abord une toute première
question d'actualité
[Musique]
la journée morte en guyane comment
est-ce que vous jugez le retard à
l'allumage du gouvernement qui donc
tarde encore à envoyer des ministres où
un ministre
pour moi le gouvernement ne peut pas se
contenter d'observer de l'extérieur ce
qui se passe en guyane il ya des
ministres il ya un ministre de
l'outre-mer au moins il ya d'autres
ministres qui sont en situation de
responsabilité
leur place est sur le terrain et donc
pour moi il est nécessaire il est
indispensable que le gouvernement prenne
ses responsabilités il est là pour ça
si vous avez des ministres si vous avez
un gouvernement c'est pour ne pas
laisser les situation se dégrader est-ce
que vous même vous comprenez la colère
des guyanais aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
soutenez leur mouvement en tout cas je
comprends n'est ce pas qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce qui est frappant pour les
guyanais et en guyane
d'abord à un décalage immense entre la
plateforme spatiale la plus haute
technologie
évidemment un univers clos protéger et
puis le reste de la guyane qui est en
retard de développement
il n'y a pas de régions en france où le
manque d'écoles souhaite aussi cruel
qu'il est ennuyeux que j'allais vous
dire il ya de nouveau des relocations à
la matière aujourd'hui à juste titre
qu'est ce que ça coûte de construire des
écoles n'y a pas besoin de chauffage en
guyana donc c'est tout à fait plausible
de votre événement de encore être sauvé
ce département peut encore être poussé
vers son développement et pas forcément
ouvrant le robinet à subventions
publiques
il suffit d'avoir des esprits pratiquer
des politiques qu'ils soient des
décisions fin d'accord mais alors vous
demandez bien sûr la présence sur place
de ministre on a entendu mais ce que le
gouvernement n'ait pas piéger
aujourd'hui avec ses revendications qui
arrive
cette flambée de revendications alors
que il ya là il ya le piège du
calendrier tout simplement du calendrier
électoral le gouvernement s'en douter
piégé parce qu'il n'a pas pris les
choses à temps c'est-à-dire que françois
nous somme n'est nullement manière il
avait présenté un plan d'avenir on a
fait des promesses et
toujours les promesses sont perdus dans
les sables est pour moi un politique
c'est fait pour ou sa vocation est de
faire pas seulement de parler de ce
hexacoeurs les deux laissez vous voilà
tant que c'est un avertissement à tous
les candidats et ce sans doute un
engagement de celui que vous soutenez
emmanuel macron on va parler de la
campagne présidentielle maintenant
françois bayrou avec jean francis
pécresse le directeur de la rédaction de
radio classique qui nous rejoint bonsoir
l'enfance et soir michel bonsoir
françois bayrou alors est ce que cette
campagne présidentielle qui exacerbe le
ras-le-bol des français ce qu'elle est
dangereuse
est ce qu'en d'autres termes elle peut
déboucher sur un accident démocratique
une élection de marine le pen toute
élection peut déboucher sur un résultat
qu'on n'attend pas et que pour certains
on ne souhaite pas c'est pas ça la
question mais pour moi voyez alors que
beaucoup de voix dix mais cette élection
c'est pas normal on découvre des choses
moi je trouve cette élection où cette
campagne électorale absolument
révélatrice de quoi ce qui est en train
d'apparaître sous nos yeux c'est le
caractère des composés de la vie
politique française et plus spécialement
le caractère des composés des deux
partis qu'ils exercent ensemble ou
alternativement le monopole du pouvoir
depuis 50 ans c'est parce que nous avons
ces pratiques que nous avons sous les
yeux
toutes ces dérives il ya eu des accès en
enlever oui j'avais appelé vous même là
les relances de vos voeux laissez-moi
aller un peu plus loin pour qu'on
comprenne les choses dans une démocratie
normale pourquoi ces pratiques
sont-elles impossible elles sont
impossibles parce qu'il ya une
surveillance une régulation un contrôle
et un équilibre vous reconnaîtrez la
formule britannique check and balance un
contrôle et un équilibre qui empêche les
les pratiques inacceptables d'avoir lieu
mais si vous n'avez pas
c'est ce pluralisme qui fait que vous
avez des gens qui portent les yeux sur
ce qui se passe si vous n'avez pas cela
alors les mauvaises pratiques prospère
et le fait qu'il n'y ait que deux
parties entraîne un phénomène que vous
connaissez bien qu'ils aient je te tiens
tu me tiens par la barbichette
c'est à dire je sais ce que tu fais mais
comme je fais la même chose on va pas se
chercher des poux dans la tête on va
s'épargner les uns les autres et c'est
ceci qui à mon avis pose le problème
démocratique principal dans lequel nous
sommes est ce que quand même quand vous
entendez françois fillon manière très
prosaïque mettre en cause l'existence
d'un cabinet noir à l'elysée ou en tout
cas d'un système de remontée
d'informations des affaires d'une forme
d'organisation d'instrumentalisation de
la justice à des fins politiques
est-ce qu'il a totalement tort moi elle
vous donne les torts sont d'un seul côté
moi qui ai un peu de mémoire des
cabinets noirs j'en ai vu tape on a
compté nausées j'en ai vu à d'autres
époques dans le don dans les décennies
passées de la vie politique française et
je n'ai pas du tout le sentiment
feuilleter les livres non pas avec des
souvenirs précis les livres d'histoire
récente à météo pour moi après avant
oui il ya eu évidemment une imprimante
et je n'ai pas le sentiment
qu'aujourd'hui on soit dans cette
situation là en tous les cas ce qui est
frappant pour moi je les sais que ce que
ce complotisme la wii c'est deux choses
premièrement c'est un enfermement
c'est fait pour que vos troupes ce soit
soit soit le plus mobilisés et le plus
poussée dans les flambées de la passion
et ce n'est pas une bonne chose
et deuxièmement c'est toujours le même
réflexe c'est pas ma faute c'est la
faute des autres
iliad est à dire si vous prenez
l'ensemble des pratiques qui sont
dévoilées aucune d'entre elle ne vient
de l'extérieur y attendait arrêtons nous
sur ce sujet aucune de ces aucun de ces
faits n'a été commandés ou provoquer de
l'extérieur ce que on reprocherait si
c'était vrai c'est un dévoilement mais
un dévoilement de choses qui sont pas
contestés et donc moi je pense qu'il
faut rompre avec les écoutes c'est pas
de ma faute c'est la faute des réseaux
anormal les écoute mais il n'y a pas un
livre dont françois fillon lui-même
appelé a fait état qui est un livre
écrit par des journalistes du canard
enchaîné qui est très bien informé qui
est qui révèle en particulier un système
qui est piloté par là des séries
d'ecoute de personnalités politiques
entre autres
est ce que vous vous avez le sentiment
que vous êtes écouté par exemple d'abord
c'est ch le coutaller mari luz et voir
si dick alexis je suis ait été je m'en
fiche
vous pouvez comprendre ça non c'est à
dire votre indignation l'avion il est
quand même attendait jouer quand même
une attentat d'abord basser deuxièmement
je ne crois pas l'être
ouais et troisièmement on ne peut être
écoutées en france que sur ordre d'un
magistrat et si quelqu'un manque à cette
obligation est bien que c'est pas vrai
attendez
vous êtes un journaliste vous affirmer
que ce n'est pas vrai non mais moi qui
suis un responsable public vous allez
m'apporter des preuves ça m'intéresse
moi qui suis un responsable public jeudi
qu'il n'y a des coûte
il n'ya d'ecoute légal en france que des
coudes par un magistral enfin décidée
par un magistrat alors vous êtes dans
vous allez à présent que vous êtes dans
le monde des bisounours là vous savez
bien que c'est écouter excusez moi vous
êtes je suis un républicain qui croient
que la république à des lois si vous
vous pensez vous devez titrait à la une
des échos demain
c'est votre journal et c'est votre
référence à un livre de valeur les vins
non non non non non vous affirmer ici
non pas la raison nous vous venez de
dire monsieur bayrou je vous pose une
question
vous me posez pas une question vous
faites une affirmation enfin vous dites
monsieur bayrou sur le monde des
bisounours vous croyez que moi je crois
qu'en france la loi est respectée
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait quelqu'un
qui puisse brancher des écoutes sans la
décision d'un magistrat d'un juge
d'instruction dans des affaires donner
parce qu'on soupçonne un certain nombre
de choses
si vous pensez le contraire vous avez le
devoir de l'écrire à la une des airbags
et et le journal de ma rue des carmes et
j'attendais s'est déchargée parfaitement
compris et en disgrâce
essayons de essayons de saisir on vit
dans ce pays dont un livre je n'ai pas
lu je ne sais pas on vit dans ce pays
par insinuation dans les éternels quand
les jours avis ce sont pas des journaux
les plus sérieux
ce sont des choses écrites en les
journalistes des journaux les plus
sérieux d'investiguer reprennent ces
insinuations sait pas d un cygne noir je
dis qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas
quelque chose de pourri dans le royaume
de danemark
alors écoutez bien ton coeur de ce livre
n'a même pas cité les rades shakespeare
c'est un menu place beauvau bienvenue
place beauvau
un livre qui inspire d'ailleurs
plusieurs ténors proche de françois
fillon qui demande aujourd'hui
l'ouverture d'une information judiciaire
vous avez vu cela qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette demande donc de 5 proche
de françois fillon qui demande
effectivement une ouverture d'une classe
de choc il demande l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire
on va voir si le parquet se saisit ou
pas
s'il ya quelque chose de sérieux le
parquet doit se saisir et on doit aller
au bout des navettes des investigations
mais ça n'est pas fait pour qu'il y ait
une enquête
c'est fait pour accréditer l'idée qu'il
existe une manoeuvre c'est c'est un
argument de campagne électoral
quant à mettre en place au moment de la
prochaine législature une commission d'
enquête sur ces allégations ou sur
d'autres d'accord pour moi c'est d'accès
très simple je me suis toujours battu
pour la transparence et le député dans
la politique je me suis battu contre les
affaires et dans des lieux où je suis
sûr parce que désormais la justice est
saisie ou qu'il y a eu des des
escroqueries des complicités enfin
toutes ces affaires là parce que j'avais
envie de me battre aussi contre le
tribunal médiatique par exemple cette
célébration qualité design écolo dès la
semaine dernière c'est la notion alors
mais moi je dis une chose avec certitude
s'il n'y avait pas eu une presse libre 1
les affaires auxquelles je faisais
allusion à l'instant ne serait jamais
sortie jamais celle que nous découvrons
et les précédentes parce que dieu sait
qu'il ya eu des affaires c'est la presse
libre qui les a fait sortir et c'est
pourquoi je dis vous avez une
responsabilité et donc in donc vous
cette m'étais que la république n'est
parfois pas aussi irréprochable a bien
su légal que vous penser parfois et non
non non non non sens là non non non non
allons au bout des zidane ne nous
arrêtons pas nous arranger les tirs nord
mais ne nous arrêtons pas des formules
de cet ordre je viens d'écrire un livre
qui traite largement de ce sujet et je
dis que pour défendre la république il
ya deux choses il ya la liberté de la
presse et l'indépendance de la juste
dernière minute sur l'indépendance de la
justice
excusez moi de dire on vient de voir un
ministre de l'intérieur qui vient de
sauter parce que la presse a révélé un
certain nombre de choses sur ces
pratiques
est ce que vous vous souvenez d'un temps
où le ministre de l'intérieur ait sauté
comme ça sur affirmations de la presse
moi je ne connais pas assez le
gouvernement de l'état verse s'agit
qu'il exécute
non mais c'est très glissant responsable
il faut parler très bien quand il y à
des désordres et des dérives liberté de
la presse et indépendance de la justice
forment un ensemble un couple qui permet
de défendre nos principes les plus
précieux et c'est pourquoi je me battrai
toujours pour l'independent pour la
liberté de la presse est toujours pour
l'indépendance de la justice
merci beaucoup rouge en france s à leurs
questions assure avec deborah claude de
la fp qui arrive l'épreuve de vérité
avec les fps que emmanuel macron et le
fils héritier
le dauphin de françois hollande pour qui
vous avez d'ailleurs appelé à voter en
j'espère que non marié et je suis sûr
que que emmanuel macron a fait quelque
chose qu'aucun des autres n'a fait il
est sorti du gouvernement pour rompre
avec la pratique antérieure
quand vous êtes sûre il n'a pas le
dauphin moubarak leur la preuve en a été
apportée par le fait qu' il est sorti du
gouvernement
personne d'autre dans des circonstances
comme celles là et tord ministre de
l'économie est en mise de l'économie
assez jeune à l'âge de giscard pour
simplifier
personne d'autre n'a fait ce choix de
rompre avec l'équipe à laquelle il
appartenait avec le président de la
république dont il avait été le
collaborateur pour dire non je ne peux
plus non je ne peux plus accepter ça
alors il a inspiré la politique
économique du gouvernement
je l' ai moi même dit et répété je vais
prendre un exemple c'est lui qui a fait
de cice les les ans aucun suggéré le 6 7
e les entreprises ne s'en plaignent pas
du cic eux mais moi quand il a décidé le
cicr j'ai dit ça va être une usine à gaz
il 2
vrai procéder par baisse de choc vous
êtes prêt à travailler avec jean yves le
drian avec des poids lourds du
gouvernement avec toute ma famille à
défaut mais vous savez on gamme - le
renouvellement que vous vous savez bien
que ce sont des sensibilités proches
vous savez bien que depuis qu elle
quelles différences substantielles y
at-il entre eux monsieur le drian et
monsieur juppé
quelle différence ils ont ils ont exercé
des responsabilités semblable avec la
même idée du devoir de la vocation de la
france
et bien moi je trouve que il est logique
qu'un jour ces sensibilités se rapproche
je prétends qu'il n'ya qu'une majorité
sérieuse en france une majorité
cohérente
c'est ce que j'ai appelé l'arc central
ya plus de majorité à droite
vous voyez bien que les que les propos
de monsieur retailles ou de monsieur
wauquiez d'un certain nombre d'autres
sont des propos que le front national en
tançant sans protester et ils ont des
thèmes qui sont des thèmes absolument
semblables et de la même manière il ya
une partie de la droite républicaine qui
n'est pas sur cette ligne
elles s'étaient regroupés autour de
juppé au moment de la primaire elle
n'est pas sur ces noms vous êtes prêts à
déblayer avec et dont jean yves le drian
est bien mais on va composer eux
je crois qu'il ya 10 ministre de jacques
chirac
peut-être 11 qui au 12 qui soutiennent
macron aujourd'hui ils ont paru mal
d'anciens de nicolas sarkozy ne sont pas
fiables mercier ils ont pas renier leurs
convictions demain dominique de villepin
ce sera une belle prise pour emmanuel
vague pas des prises c'est pas des
prises tout ça se fait au terme de
réflexion de débat de conscience
d'hommes et de femmes qui sont devant
une situation qui est une situation pour
eux insupportable et ingérable
et qui disent il faut en sortir
moi je suis solidaire avec tous ceux qui
constatant la décomposition de la vie
politique du pays disent il faut en
sortir
je le dis depuis plus longtemps que
j'accepte l'ancien je trouve je trouve
qu'il y ait 15 15 ans qu'on voit se
préparer
ce phénomène de décomposition avancée la
décomposition
il est temps d'arracher le pouvoir à ces
deux organismes politiques le ps et l
air qui sont des organismes politiques
usées dont les pratiques les méthodes le
sectarisme empêche que la france avance
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
très content de ce choix alors et vous
êtes prêt aussi à travailler avec
l'ancien premier ministre manuel valls
que vous avez raison on va on va avoir
ce ce qu'il dit les choix qu'il fait
mais je suis et moi ça me gêne pas de
dire que c'est quelqu'un que j'estime de
jeu je trouve que que la vie politique
française je les écris aussi dans ce
livre est la vie politique française
manque de l'expression de cette estime
là je peux être en désaccord avec
quelqu'un et avoir de l'estimé pour lui
j'ai été en désaccord assez souvent avec
manuel valls
il se trouve cependant que j'ai données
que j'ai de l'estimé pour lui par
exemple on dit que emmanuel macron
peut-être lui-même lui demande de ne pas
le rejoindre pour l'instant vous avez
des informations à la rue il ya deux
mois je crois qu'il ya une chose
extrêmement importante
oui c'est que on évite toute ambiguïté
que monsieur tout à l'heure le défenseur
de monsieur fillon manier avec dextérité
il ya deux attitudes il ya le soutien et
le soutien il est légitime qu'il soit
large et puis il y à l'exercice des
responsabilités et l'exercice des
responsabilités doit être cohérent et
porter le renouveau l'équipe
gouvernementale par hypothèse si
emmanuel macron est élu doit être une
équipe absolument renouveler avec des
ça je ne serai pas des méthodes et des
pratiques nouvelles sans vos et donc
excusez moi je ne suis pas membre du
gouvernement sortant
je ne suis pas même je ne suis pas
membre du gouvernement précédent
je ne suis pas membre du gouvernement
hanté précédent il se trouve que j'ai
quitté cette cette pratique que je me
suis opposé depuis
en effet un temps assez long donc vous
vous rené ans au moins en capacité
d'exercer des responsabilités ces jeux
vous sinon vous ne dites pas je vais
reprendre je vais vous surprendre
oui surprenez nous je n'ai jamais parlé
de ce sujet avec emmanuel macron et sur
son étoffe présidentielle alors vous
faites toujours allusion à sa jeunesse
je vais vous dire il va être élu à l'âge
où john kennedy a été à deux ans et john
kennedy a été élu à 43 ans lui va être
élu à 40 ans et 43 ans au début des
années 60
c'est plus jeune que 40 ans aujourd'hui
et donc eu jeu c'est à peu près
similaire était en train de lire de lire
un roman sur les débuts de kennedy et on
lui faisait les mêmes reprocher
exactement
donc voilà il ya des moments dans
l'histoire des peuples où les choses
sont tellement décomposés que on a
besoin de jeunesse fait confiance
d'accord président débat autrement je ne
serais pas là d'accord en tous les cas
vous dites il sera élu mais aucun doute
je n'ai pas dit sera élu se disent à
réjean temps de venir lorsqu'il sera
enfin il sera élu à l'âge ça veut dire
s'il est élu leur à l'âge merci dévora
troisième partie de l'épreuve de vérité
maintenant avec mickey la messe de
public sénat qui nous rejoint
[Musique]
père michael 11 ans michel rousseaux
subaru boudine depuis des années vouloir
cette victoire de cette majorité
centrale
si jamais emmanuel macron gagne
l'élection présidentielle à quoi
ressemblerait cette majorité s'en sera
centrale que vous appelez de vos voeux
c'est d'une majorité profondément
renouvelée dans les visages
parce que la promesse que porte emmanuel
macron c'est une promesse de renouveau
c'est que on sorte de l'usure dans
laquelle on est enfermé ça c'est la
première chose
la deuxième chose c'est une majorité
pluraliste
c'est à dire qu'on n'aura pas le le
l'illusion d'avoir un seul cap
enfin eu un seul parti une seule
organisation à une seule idéologie on
aura une majorité qui reconnaîtra
hétéroclite
nous employons à hétéroclite déjà
reparti écoutez moi bien c'est la
majorité la plus cohérente qui puisse
exister en france majorité cohérente de
gauche c'est impossible aujourd'hui
vous en êtes d'accord majorité cohérente
de droite c'est impossible au journal
que dit françois fillon
mais c'est pas parce que françois fillon
dit quelque chose c'est un en rien ma
françois fillon est aujourd'hui à 18 %
dans les sondages
parfois moi enfin dit je m'étends 18%
marine le pen est à 25% ou et où est la
majorité de droite
où est la cohérence d'une majorité de
droite de quoi on parle
pour faire une majorité ça arrivait à
plus de 50%
il faut arriver à plus de 50% de gens
qui s'entendent entre eux qui est allé à
des nuances près les mêmes options
fondamentales
est ce que je constate dans la majorité
emmanuel macron préparent ou qui se
prépare autour de lui je constate deux
choses la première c'est que c'est le
seul candidat aujourd'hui qu'ils
obtiennent des
des soutiens des ralliements des
ralliements les personnalités des
personnalités nombreux par l'avocat pas
de structure politique là à part la
mienne c'est déjà pas si mal et ensuite
il a des personnalités nombreuses
d'expérience je dis je crois c'est douze
ministres de jacques chirac même au
début vous disais un certain non
renouvellement des visages donc c'est un
protagoniste n'ont donc des soutiens ça
ne gène pas d'accord dans les soutiens
il est tout à fait normal qu'ils aient
des experts mais le renouvellement est
nécessaire donc une majorité large
j'observe qu'il y a des soutiens
nombreux et j'ajoute que toutes ces
personnalités pour 98% d'entre eux sont
cohérentes entre elles
je répète contre jean yves le drian d'un
côté et ont parlé d'alain juppé ou de
tel autre qui les fonctions de ministre
de la défense ou des responsabilités
dans les affaires étrangères les axes
sont les mêmes il ya des nuances légère
avec manioli cautionner do i réveillant
se passe je vais je vais le dire de la
manière la plus simple que je connaisse
pour avoir une politique économique qui
fasse sa part à la liberté et au soutien
aux entreprises et une politique qui
revendique un cap de solidarité sont
tous d'accord ceux qui sont là sont pas
d'accord à droite ils sont pas d'accord
avec vous mais comment le doute demeure
comme un an et bien moi je vous dis
qu'on avait ordonné de doute mais comme
un jeu ds quillorama des combines gens
qui nous ramène à la ivème république et
bien je crois exactement le contraire
parce que cette alliance qui formera la
majorité présidentielle or à 577
candidats dans les 577 circonscriptions
du pays
il faudra pas négocier le vrai par loin
amendement par amendement sur moi ma
nana je vais prendre à paris je suis
persuadé que cette majorité su persuader
c'est un pari peut être personnel cette
majorité là elle sera plus large que les
autres et elle sera à coup sûr plus
cohérente que les os empêcheront
on grave que bien sûr parce qu'il y aura
un cadre il y aura un contrat comme dit
emmanuel macron je vais je vais un peu
plus plus loin cette majorité là elle
sera la traduction en une vague de ce
que les français auront exigé en votant
pour emmanuel macron au mois de mai mais
monsieur le savent assure manuel valls
il doit visiblement annoncer des choses
dans les prochains jours vous le
connaissez vous l'avez rencontré m
vous l'avez duré longtemps mais oui et
vous l'avez rencontré est-ce qu'il peut
être aujourd'hui l'incarnation du
leadership des progrès si de demain à
saint je ne veux d'abord j'aime pas le
mot progressiste il ya je sais bien qu
emmanuel macron ludique où je sais bien
que manuel valls l'utilisent
moi je ne sais pas ce que progressiste
veut dire il ya en moi parlons de la
majorité de néanmoins autant de
progressisme entre guillemets que deux
conservateurs parce que je pense qu'il
ya des domaines entiers de la vie dans
lesquels ils forcent est majoritaire
devrait être des choses qui existent
l'éducation par exemple on transmet une
langue qui existent on transmet des lois
mathématiques qui existent sur la côte
est donc non mais c'est très très
important donc permettez moi d'avoir mon
propre vocabulaire est ce que montrent
les relevés employé mon propre vocale si
ce que je crois moi c'est que il y a en
effet un grand courant réformiste en
france grands courants qui pensent que
le pays doit pour faire face aux
exigences du temps choisir la voie de la
réforme progressive
on identifie un problème on règle le
problème en se fixant comme règle qu'on
ne n'organise pas la fracture de la
société française c'est ça le réformer
entre ces cinq manuels révolutionnaire
non je dis je parle d' emmanuel macron
et de la proposition que nous faisons
après tout le monde se situent par
rapport à cette vocation réformer leur
là après pour le reste il ya du passé
d vous dites avec du passé faisons table
rase oui moi moi je suis plutôt pour
rassembler mais je reconnais que il faut
parfois user de persuasion il y aura
vers un temps pour persuader les gens de
2 sera signera pas d'accord avec les
états majors niant aujourd'hui même et
manuela gross sauf avec le modem oui
sauf avec le modem oui parce que ce
qu'amène emmanuel macron c'est
précisément la fin du pouvoir du ps que
d'efforts monsieur hamon la fin du
pouvoir de l'ump devenu l air que défend
monsieur fillon c'est pour arracher le
pouvoir à ces deux appareils épuisé qu
emmanuel macron s'est présenté devant le
pays et c'est pour ça qu'il a le succès
que nous savons et c'est pourquoi je
suis ateliers avec lui merci michael
merci françois bayrou alain j avoue
[Musique]